bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo votre rendez-vous avec
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine bonjour au dos jean
emmanuel bonjour à tous et on voit tout
de suite les titres de l'actualité
dominante cette semaine avec tout
d'abord restera restera pas supputations
autour d'un possible départ de matignon
de françois fillon nicolas sarkozy n'est
pas mon mentor par une petite phrase sur
france 2 le premier ministre marque ses
distances avec le chef de l'état le
projet de loi de finances pour 2011
présenté en conseil des ministres et
déjà la guerre des mots réduction des
niches fiscales le gouvernement hausse
déguisée des impôts pour l'opposition
ça promet tant le débat budgétaire et le
projet de loi besson sur l'immigration
votre ytrac sur l'article sur la
déchéance de nationalité le virage
sécuritaire critique et au delà de
l'hexagone
l'hebdomadaire américain newsweek à ceux
ci nicolas sarkozy à la montée de
l'extrême droite en europe est avec nous
sur ce plateau hervé morin bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous accueille avec
plaisir vous êtes ministre de la défense
président du nouveau centre une
formation qui fait partie de la majorité
à l'assemblée
vous allez commenter avec chemin aussi
et au scénario tout à fait alors vous et
comment tes potes un peu ric rac à se
diviser un peu le combat intense rieu le
groupe centriste est divisée mais les
sénateurs nouveaux centres existent ils
sont onze autant que les députés et on
parlera aussi des intentions pour 2012
si vous le voulez bien chez vous où les
interrogations existentielles des
centristes alors mais d'abord évidemment
une question sur cette photo ce document
sonore des sept otages au niger diffusé
par al qaïda au maghreb
est ce que vous y voyez un signal pour
entamer des négociations
ils ont que pour nous c'est un signe
encourageant
mais nous n'avons qu'une revendication
d'aucune sorte vous disiez que la grande
difficulté c'était justement de rentrer
en contact avec les preneurs d'otages
vous savez nous avons en mémoire ce qui
s'est passé pour michel germaneau
et pour michel germaneau nous n'avons
jamais pu rentrer en discussion avec les
ravisseurs est donc le fait d'avoir
cette image est pour nous un signal
plutôt encourageants et positifs pas du
tout la date ce que nous avons fait
c'est que nous avons authentifier cette
image en revanche ne savons pas quand
elle a été prise
oui mais ça ça c'est ce sont des
suppositions n'avons aucun élément
concret précis nous permettant pouvoir
indiquer où cette photo a été prise et
quand elle a été prise c'est une
introduction quand même vous pensez un
signal il faut le vivre d'autant plus de
temps plus comme un signal dans la
mesure où comme vous l'aurez remarqué la
photo c'est la photo de nos cinq
compatriotes alors qu'il y à sept otages
donc on peut penser qu'il y à là en
quelque sorte un message adressé à la
france
pour michel germaneau il y avait une
revendication de libération de
prisonniers conduits en france non non
il y avait une revendication générale et
absolue de re2 de libération de
prisonniers mais sans qu'à aucun moment
nous n'ayons plus d'indications
d'ailleurs à un tel point que lorsque
nous avons voulu faire en sorte que
michel germaneau puisse continuer à être
soigné puisqu'il souffrait d'une maladie
imposant une pharmacopée permanente
eh bien nous n'avons jamais pu lui
transmettre les médicaments vous
collaborez sur place avec les
gouvernements locaux alors le mali dit
que vous vous souhaitez l'aide justement
du mali notamment ce que nous faisons
avec les gouvernements locaux c'est que
nous faisons des coopérations notamment
avec la mauritanie qui est plus avancé
que le mali est que le niger notamment
parce qu'au niger vous connaissez la vie
politique du niger de ces derniers mois
mais avec la mauritanie notamment nous
avons lancé des coopérations et des
formations permettant aux mauritaniens
et nous l'espérons demain
au niger rien de disposer de forces
capables de lutter contre le terrorisme
assez pour le long terme et pour le
contexte général
voilà merci on va revenir bien sûr
maintenant sur l'agenda de la semaine et
cette question retour à la politique
intérieure françois fillon c'était lundi
va-t-il partir oui lundi les
déclarations chocs de françois fillon la
veille sur france 2 qui agite la classe
politique le premier ministre dit ne pas
se préoccuper des supputations mais il
les a incontestablement alimenté en
évoquant notamment d'un ton très libre
de nouveaux challenges
anaïs goba tian c'est une phrase lourde
de conséquences
nicolas sarkozy n'a jamais été mon
mentor j'ai fait alliance avec lui j'ai
choisi de l'aider à être président de la
république et je
on félicite tous les jours françois
fillon qui prend ses distances avec le
chef de l'état à quelques semaines d'un
remaniement annoncé depuis cet été
il n'en fallait pas plus pour animer les
médias à l'ump en tout cas
l'interprétation est différente il ya
absolument rien dans les propos de
françois fillon contrairement à ce que
vous laissez entendre qu'il soit dirigée
contre le président de la république
de la même façon que je vois les deux
hommes travaillent et je vois à quel
point la confiance entre eux ils forcent
françois fillon qui dans l'interview se
démarque de la droite libérale incarnée
par nicolas sarkozy une différence
inexistante pour les socialistes nous
n'oublierons pas au milieu de la fable
qui ont raconté sur moi c'est moi lui
celi nous n'oublierons pas nous que lui
l'ont sarkozy c'est byzance fillon et
vice versa fillon-sarkozy fait bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet
françois fillon résistera-t-il au
prochain remaniement personne ne peut
encore le dire mais le premier ministre
est serein et il se dit prêt à relever
de nouveaux défis
alors ce document cette interview est ce
que c'est le testament d'un premier
ministre qui va partir un discours
d'adieu comment voyez ça coûte et
honnêtement moi j'ai vécu comme
simplement un témoignage de trois ans et
demi à la tête de matignon après comme
un remaniement a été annoncé depuis
plusieurs semaines
bien entendu on après on brode et on
raconte une histoire
je crois qu'il faut
faut pas y voir autre chose que
simplement l'expression d'un premier
ministre qui rappelle son parcours
politique qui son parcours politique
personnel et dont clément vivante on
sait que il est d'abord et avant tout
l'homme qui pendant très longtemps a
suivi philippe seguin en même temps à mi
mots par exemple ils critiquent le style
même de nicolas sarkozy en faisant
apparaître que lui est plus sobre
peut-être écoutez moi je veux pas
rentrer dans tout cela j'ai eu la chance
d'être avec un premier ministre qui qui
est un homme qui a un vrai sens de
l'état
vous dites j'ai eu vous pensé à ça va se
terminer j'ai eu j'ai écouté je suis
désolé mais la langue française il n'y a
pas le plus ample perfect comme en
anglais donc je parle du passé et du
présent j'ai appris pour la casse qui
s'y est inquiète un premier ministre et
un vrai sens de l'état
bré sens des responsabilités qu'à une
capacité d'écouté de dialogue et qui en
plus pour moi connaissez très bien les
questions militaires et donc j'ai
apprécié j'apprécie encore tous les
jours de travail et que françois fillon
et le prochain gouvernement vous y voyez
enfin écoutez moi j'exerce une
responsabilité qui est imminente
je suis à la tête d'une communauté de
300 mille hommes qui un sens du devoir
un sens de la mission
aujourd'hui nous avons cinq otages dans
le sahel il ya quatre mille hommes
d'engager en afghanistan j'exercerai
cette responsabilité aussi longtemps qu
on me permettra d'aller exercer de lire
cette semaine dans la presse a sûrement
vu que le président qui a l'habitude de
tutoyer vous donne maintenant du
monsieur le ministre de la défense et
que ce serait un mauvais présage pour
représente vraiment très honnêtement ça
m'avait échappé
ils m'appellent monsieur mise la défense
comme il lui arrive d'appeler tel ou tel
ministre de par ses fonctions
et puis dans la réunion suivante de le
tutoyer d'appeler par son prénom
je ne pose pas ces questions là pour moi
c'est une c c'est pas une question dans
la mesure où toute façon saine ça n'est
pas une décision qui relève de votre
responsabilité
la composition du gouvernement c'est
ainsi c'est le présent la république et
le premier ministre qui la nomme
et donc vous n'avez pas question vous
posez là dessus est-ce que vous
souhaitez que lors d'autres événements y
est ainsi plus amples ou une ouverture
plus grande vers les centristes coûté
des centristes sont dans la majorité
ces choix que nous avons fait en 2007
nous voulions participer à la
transformation du pays
nous avons nous sommes opposés à la
démarche de françois bayrou qui avait
décidé de rompre avec sa famille
politique et donc que je souhaite bien
entendu que les centristes ce soit le
plus nombreux aussi nous on est dans
l'eau il est à l'ump pour moi c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose suivante
j'évoque les centristes qui sont dans
une formation politique autonome et
indépendante de l'ump
alors en ce que la famille centriste
doit avoir une expression politique qui
lui est propre ne dépendant d'aucun
autre partie parce que le message
centriste doit exister dans la vie
politique française nous sommes les sols
par exemple à défendre l'idée que la
construction européenne ce n'est pas la
construction simplement d'un d'une
puissance commerciale que l'europe ça
doit être un projet politique et vous
voyez bien que dans l' équilibre du
monde nous et quand même conscience de
choses majeur c'est que le monde est en
train de basculer le monde est en train
de passer des rives de l'atlantique aux
rives de l'océan indien et du pacifique
et pendant ce temps les européens
continuent à réduire leurs budgets de
défense et donc se met en situation
d'être progressivement un protectorat et
d'être sous condominium sino-américain
dans quarante ou dans 50 ans donc rien
face à cela nous centristes nous
défendons l'idée que l'europe doit
porter un idée un projet d'être une
puissance capable de défendre son modèle
de société qui est pour moi le meilleur
des modèles de société un projet
millions que les centristes sont un
projet politique ils doivent défendre et
en toute autonomie est ce qu'il faut en
conclure que selon vous les centristes
doivent avoir pour défendre ce projet un
candidat à la présidence a ne fait pour
moi aucun doute aucun doute le doit y
avoir quelqu'un à côté de nick donc il y
aura 10 colas sarkozy probablement mais
il faut aussi qu'il y ait une
coordination
je vous
appelle une chose c'est l'histoire
l'histoire c'est qu'il ya toujours eu un
sens triste c'est que ces centristes il
a eu un écho dans l'opinion publique qui
a toujours entre 15 et 20% de français
et même une fois un homme qui a été lui
s'appelait valéry giscard d'estaing et
que ces français là ils ont droit de
d'avoir une expression politique
ils ont droit de compter dans la vie
pratique en fait ils ont droit de
pouvoir participer à la définition et
aux arbitrages de la vie politique
française
d'une part et d'autre part si vous me
permettez qui peut croire un seul
instant que dans une société où l'offre
est multiple dans tous les compartiments
de votre vie
le seul domaine qui est pourtant le
domaine le plus précieux qui est celui
de la démocratie on estimerait que
l'offre elle doit être unique
bon alors le candidat qui vous verra
bien à l'automne les secousses vous vous
vous l'aviez laissé entendre un peu cet
été puis vous avez semblé reculer une
chirurgie jamais le tulle est c'est vous
qui avait convié toujours partant région
sam notre jeu j'ai je suis président du
nouveau centre qui est la principale
formation centriste de la majorité
nous sommes dans la majorité nous
considérons que nous devons avoir une
expression propre cette expression
propre elle passe pour le président de
la formation que je suis par un candidat
il appartiendra aux militants de le
décider à l'automne 2011
sarkozy son métier il est hostile à
cette candidature de centre-droit vous
passerez autres et gd recevait la
démocratie c'est d'abord le peuple qui
dessert des avoirs j'ai eu des
conversations sur ce sujet en son temps
mais je vous rappelle simplement des
choses aussi simples que celles ci c'est
que les hommes et les femmes qui n'ont
pas voté nicolas sarkozy au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle en 2007
il leur faudra bien quelqu'un pour
exprimer ce qu'il tombe à les lundis
toujours une avancée dans le dossier
woerth bettencourt elle provient du
premier procureur de france jean louis
nadal qui recommande la nomination d'un
juge d'instruction pour poursuivre
l'enquêté concernant eric woerth est une
qui se réjouit alors c'est eva joly
figure de proue d'europe écologie et
surtout ex juge d'instruction elle
écoute c'est la ccit
d'un juge d'instruction dans les
affaires bettencourt woerth est pour moi
une décision qui sauve l'honneur la
justice dans notre pays et qui est une
garantie pour nous tous qu'il y aurait
là une véritable enquête et non pas des
100 kg est circonscrit et qu'on va se
servir de tous les instruments prévus
dans le code pénal pour découvrir la
vérité
alors cette nouvelle pour l'instant a
fait un peu flop car le procureur de
nanterre philippe courroye a dit qu'il
entendait poursuivre ses enquêtes
préliminaires ce qui laisse entendre
qu'il ne compte pas pour l'instant nommé
deux juges d'instruction est-ce que
arrêt morin vous trouvez que le parquet
le procureur courroye en l'occurrence à
un peu trop de pouvoir sur cette affaire
puisqu'il pour l'instant de façon
solitaire il peut mener ses
investigations sans contradiction il
faut savoir que 98 % des enquêtes ce
fonceur juge d'instruction en france
celle ci est appelée équité écoutez moi
j'aimerais tellement qu'on essaie
d'avoir le comportement que peuvent
avoir les britanniques le pouvoir
politique en grande-bretagne commente
jamais une procédure judiciaire
et j'aimerais tellement qu'on intègre
l'idée que la séparation des pouvoirs
que nous avons porté à travers
montesquieu et bien que cette séparation
des pouvoirs nous l'application dans
notre comportement permanent s'est
déroulé on laisse les magistrats faire
leur travail et qu'en même temps on
cesse de supputer commenté considérer
que telle ou telle serait sous influence
et ses rafales à on n'est pas du tout
dans la séparation des pouvoirs encore
moins vous êtes d'accord
courroye directement enfin jusqu'à
nouvel ordre le procureur courroye ne
reçoit pas que téléphone tous les matins
pour savoir ce qu'il fait on passe à la
que l'idée de mardi à l'assemblée
nationale un projet de loi très
controversé
mardi l'immigration revient donc sur le
devant de la scène à l'assemblée
nationale l'opposition monte au créneau
contre le sixième texte gouvernemental
en huit ans mais eric besson justifie
son projet de loi par l'obligation de
transposer des directives européennes on
les écoute sous présidence française
c'était mon prédécesseur qu'il était à
l'initiative
nous avons adopté les 27 pays de l'union
européenne
un pacte européen de l'immigration et de
l'asile que nous déclinons étape après
étape
c'est une politique est suivie dans tous
les pays de l'union européenne quelle
que soit la sensibilité politique
je travaille avec les socialistes
espagnols les socialistes grecs
les socialistes portugais et naguère
avec les travaillistes britanniques sans
aucune difficulté
alors la disposition la plus
controversée de ce texte la déchéance de
nationalité qui visent des français
naturalisés depuis moins de dix ans
s'ils sont reconnus coupables du meurtre
d'un policier ou d'un gendarme elle a
été votée à une très courte majorité les
députés nouveau centre d'ailleurs
n'était pas là il était absent certains
se sentent gênés à l'ump même quelques
parlementaires ont estimé qu'il y avait
une sorte de drague vis-à-vis du front
national vous même vous n'êtes pas
embarrassé par une telle mesure
non je suis pas je suis pas embarrassés
par cette mesure pour une raison simple
c'est que il existe un certain nombre de
cas de déchéance de la nationalité
française pour ceux qui ont acquis la
nationalité française à entendre jeudi
ceux qui ont acquis la nationalité sur
une durée d'ailleurs les socialistes
n'ont pas jugé bon de supprimer ces
dispositions lorsqu'il était au pouvoir
et je considère que c'est en quelque
sorte l'extension d'un cas qui est déjà
prévu qui est celui de la déchéance de
la nationalité pour française pour les
atteintes à la sécurité de l'état donc
le meurtre d'un policier ou d'un
gendarme
c'est un peu l'expression de ce que peut
représenter un état il y avait un virage
sécuritaire
discours de grenoble cet été la
politique vis-à-vis des roms est ce
qu'on avait vu la une de newsweek sur
semaine mais nicolas sarkozy
qui montre nicolas sarkozy comme un
nouveau symbole de l'extrémisme ça n'est
pas un peu mal de voir ça ouais enfin
c'est une chaque journal fait ce qu'il
veut et chaque mois ce que je peux
champion en titre
ce que je veux porter sur cette histoire
de sécurité je les dis durant les
universités d'été c'est que on a besoin
d'une politique équilibrée
cette politique équilibrée c'est celle
qui doit concilier quatre piliers en
effet le pilier impossible mais ça ne
suffira pas vous pourrez mettre tous les
policiers les gendarmes de la terre ça
ne suffira pas pour lutter contre la
délinquance et donc il faut d'abord et
avant tout avoir un système éducatif qui
marche
un système qui s'intéresse aux personnes
et qui ne s'intéresse pas aux zones ont
fait des aides et bien lieu de faire des
zep
il faut accompagner les enfants et les
familles qui sont en difficulté et sur
la voie de l'exclusion donc c'est une
politique éducative
un enseignant ça fait plus pour la
sécurité c'est une politique dissuasive
et ça c'est notamment tout ce qui est
autour de la vidéosurveillance et la
vidéoprotection là où c'est nécessaire
et enfin il faut une politique de
deuxième chance pour celles et ceux qui
à qui il faut donner cette nouvelle
chambre
voilà sécuritaire est indispensable pour
qui veut être candidat je pense qu'une
vraie demande de sécurité en france et
que cette demande de sécurité faut pas
la traiter n'importe comment en revanche
ce qui est absolument inacceptable et
insupportable c'est quand on lit
sécurité immigration
parce que l'immigration dont on parle en
dessous qui on a eu un certain nombre de
partenaires de l'ump qui ont fait ce
champ en amalgame c'est que
l'immigration ne t'ont pas sont des
français ce sont les français qui sont
allés dans nos écoles qui sont nés dans
nos hôpitaux et qui ont grandi dans nos
ville ou en périphérie plutôt de nos
villes et moi pardon sécurité non il a
été fait par un certain nombre de
parlementaires de l'ump notamment
et moi je voudrais porter l'idée dans le
cadre de ma société de la reconnaissance
qui est celle d'une société dans
laquelle chacun est respecté héros
connu pour ce qu'il apporte eh bien je
voudrais qu'on porte un autre message
sur nos quartiers nos quartiers en effet
il ya des difficultés il ya des dealers
il ya des policiers qui ne peuvent plus
rentrer et en même temps nos quartiers
ce sont des chances et et une
potentialité extraordinaire et a
énormément d'hommes et de femmes qui
veulent réussir et ses 98 % d'entre eux
c'est une capacité extraordinaire pour
notre pays de rayonner à travers le
monde
et quand je vais dans les banlieues et
bien moi je constate une chose je dis
mais pas ce que j'y vais assez souvent
et bien je constate que l'administration
américaine elle aperçut tous ces talents
elle les a tellement la chercher elle a
organisé le recrutement de nos talents
de ce qu'ils savent de meilleure école
pour aller vendre les produits
américains parce que quand on a deux
cultures dans un monde globalisé et bien
c'est plus facile que d'avoir une seule
culture et donc je veux pas leur et
l'idée que et bien au lieu d'adresser
comme seul message à l'égard des
banlieues et des quartiers un message
négatif et bien qu'il ya un message
positif à porter parce que la plupart de
ceux qui vivent ici ils ne demandent
qu'une chose c'est être des français à
part entière et reconnu comme tel
hervé morin on continue le film de la
semaine avec ce mardi encore qui est une
mauvaise journée encore pour bernard
acoyer dans une tribune publiée dans le
monde l'ensemble des députés de
l'opposition réclament la démission du
président de l'assemblée nationale
ce qu'il ne digère pas c'est que bernard
à quoi il aurait refusé les explications
de vote à l'issue du débat sur les
retraites
haro de l'opposition sur le perchoir
c'est un sujet de yoann relais après un
premier acte très rocambolesques
l'opposition avait promis de ne pas en
rester là
michaud c'est désormais chose faite une
longue tribune parue cet après-midi dans
le monde au titre on peut plus clair un
texte devenu la lecture du jour pour les
députés socialistes et cosignée par leur
président de vaud jean marc ayrault le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
violé le règlement aura violé les droits
des députés et donc il n'y a aucune
raison de faire comme s'il ne s'était
rien passé
le parlement est méprisé déjà dans nos
institutions mais l'opposition est
écrasée donc nous voulons marquer par
notre demande notre volonté que les
choses changent vraiment socialistes
communistes verts et parti de gauche ont
décidé de faire cause commune
première étape ce matin le boycott de la
conférence des présidents la réunion de
travail hebdomadaire avec bernard
accoyer
dès cet après midi nouvelle
démonstration de force à l'arrivée du
président de l'assemblée les députés de
l'opposition refuse de se lever pour le
salut est ouverte
nous étions en face d'une manoeuvre
évidente d'obstruction je ne me sens pas
menacé dans mes fonctions tout
simplement parce que j'ai la conscience
parfaitement tranquille je fais mon
devoir de parlementaire mon devoir de
président semblait nationale en faisant
respecter d'abord notre constitution et
ensuite notre règlement dans un esprit
même qui était l'objet d'un détournement
caractérisée face aux journalistes
bernard accoyer a également fait part de
sa détermination à renouer le dialogue
dans les meilleurs délais en plein débat
sur l'immigration la mission risque
d'être difficile si vous le gouvernement
j'ai jamais aimé ce cette espèce de
comédie de boulevard
vous avez la chance d'être dans la
majorité dont de ne pas souffrir de ce
manque de droits
on se plaint l'opposition tout et le
conseil constitutionnel est là pour
éventuellement trancher les choses donc
j'imagine que le parti socialiste
saisira le conseil constitutionnel mardi
les présidents de groupes parlementaires
reçus à matignon par le premier ministre
françois fillon les a informés sur la
menace terroriste en france on écoute
les réactions à la sortie de cette
réunion
las réel il faut pas la sous-estimer il
faut il faire face et faire preuve dans
ces moments beaucoup de
ce responsable je pense que sur
communiqué tous les jours toutes les
semaines
n'améliorera pas forcément la sécurité
des français ce qui est important c'est
d'agir notamment en matière de
renseignement ce qu'on peut se demander
en tant que citoyen en tant que
responsable politique aussi c'est si la
manière de communiquer du gouvernement
français n'est pas un peu contradictoire
et ne renforce pas d'une certaine
manière la pseudo légitimité de ces
groupes terroristes en disant de nous
regarder admis bien nous sommes reconnus
en tant que force puisque le
gouvernement français par exemple
demande de négocier avec nous sur
communiqué ou non là je m'adresse
hominis de la défense aussi parce que
vous avez la plaine richard de ce qui
est en train de se passer
écoutez nous avions eu toute une série
d'informations provenant d'un certain
nombre de services d'enseignement
indiquant à une recrudescence de la
menace terroriste sur la france et sur
l'europe
sky news a parlé d'un même d'un projet
d'attentât dans des grandes villes
d'europe qui auraient été déjouées c'est
une information sérieuse nous avions des
informations concordantes émanant de
différents services nous indiquant qu'en
effet la france et l'europe étaient plus
particulièrement menacées en sachant que
la menace terroriste c'est la manne elle
est générale et permanente
bon on passe à la journée du mercredi
avec la question du jour la réduction
des niches fiscales est ce une hausse
des impôts chacun sa réponse évidemment
ce mercredi le gouvernement présente son
projet de budget pour 2011 avec pour
objectif affiché de réduire les déficits
publics pour y parvenir on rabote
notamment les niches fiscales pour un
montant d'environ 10 milliards -
davantage qui ce qu est ce que cela veut
dire payer plus d'impôts à priori oui
mais chacun répond à sa façon
johan raud là ce matin sur le perron de
l'elysée deux ministres pressé et peu
bavard
raisons protocolaires françois baroin et
christine lagarde réserve aux députés
leur premier commentaire sur le budget
ont commis sur des pilotes
raison plus officieuse le millésime 2011
risquent d'avoir du mal à passer
un suspense de courte durée alors que
les ministres prennent la pose devant la
commission des lois
copier en main les grandes lignes du
budget ont déjà été rendues publiques
dès cette année l'état devra se
désendetter de 40 milliards du coup
poursuite de la cure d'austérité dans la
fonction publique mais surtout haro sur
les niches fiscales
parmi les nouveautés l'augmentation de
la tva pour les fournisseurs d'accès à
internet et la suppression des
ristournes pour les couples qui se
marient 10 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires
mais officiellement aucune augmentation
d'impôts un tour de passe passe pour
l'opposition il va y avoir des
augmentations d'impôts sur les classes
moyennes quand les plus favorisés ont
seront dispensés du côté de la majorité
cette fois si certains reconnaissent que
les contribuables devront bel et bien se
serrer la ceinture
ce qu'on appelle pudiquement la
réduction des niches fiscales en france
et qu'ils causent ça s'appelle
augmentation des apports et quand il
s'agit par exemple d'augmenter les
impôts des nouveaux mariés de l'année
eh bien ça ne va pas et du bout des
lèvres le ministre du budget confirme
tout en promettant que les sacrifices
épargneront les plus modestes
nous essayons d'avoir un équilibre à peu
près juste entre les efforts demandés
aux ménages et aux entreprises 60 % pour
les entreprises 40% pour les ménages
celles et ceux qui ont été le plus
touchés par la crise ou qui sont les
plus fragiles sont épargnés par les
mesures d'économie qui synthétise au
fond ce budget autre tabou du
gouvernement le bouclier fiscal sera
maintenu en 2011
à l'assemblée l'opposition promet une
nouvelle fois de demander sa suppression
automatique
pourquoi ne pas dire clairement nous
nous demandions la réduction des niches
fiscales
c'était une revendication permanente des
parlementaires du nouveau centre charles
de courson qui réclamaient une réduction
de 10 milliards d'euros des niches
fiscales
alors le bouclier fiscal nous nous
vont clairement arrêt depuis depuis nous
avons voté pour faire les choses dans
l'ordre
le bouclier fiscal c'est ait eu un des
engagements du président de la
république nous avons participé au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
à son élection
et donc il est logique le nous ayons
voté le bouclier fiscal tout en
expliquant que cette réponse là serait
une réponse qui auraient des difficultés
à tenir sur le long terme
nous avons eu raison puisque vous voyez
que le bouclier fiscal est aujourd'hui
commence à être percé il a été une
première fois il le sera dans le cadre
de la réforme des retraites le bouclier
fiscal c'est une réponse à une
problématique de fond qui est celle de
l' isf de l'évasion du patrimoine et de
l'incapacité pour notre pays à pouvoir
construire un capitalisme stable un
actionnariat stable sur le long terme
pour nos entreprises c'est cela dont
nous avons besoin d'avoir des
entreprises qui sont assises et qui se
repose sur un actionnariat stable qui
leur permet de pouvoir avoir une
perspective sur le long terme et
notamment ce que je défends c'est l'idée
du développement de l'entrepreneuriat
familial c'est à dire de chefs
d'entreprise qui porte un projet et qui
en plus respecte les salariés comme un
été et un élément de la richesse de
cette entreprise est bien face à cela
nous nous défendons et je pense que le
moment des élections présidentielles
sera un moment où nous remettrons ce
sujet à l'ordre du jour la socialite est
sans doute la suppression du bouclier
fiscal qui a en effet sur le long terme
ne tiendra pas la suppression de l'sf
qui est un mauvais impôt et qui est un
impôt imbécile que tous les pays
européens ont supprimé et pour que le
système soit juste une tranche marginale
d'impôt sur le revenu supplémentaire de
même sur le
il faut que notre pays se mettent en
situation d'affronter la globalisation
sprint est une idéologie la
globalisation ça en fait
et donc nous aurons un autre grand sujet
latéral celui de la transformation de
nos prélèvements sociaux on ne peut pas
continuer à faire peser sur le train se
faire poser sur le travail la totalité
des financements la sécurité sociale et
donc nous défendons-nous l'idée d'un
impôt sur la consommation
éventuellement couplé
d'un impôt sur l'environnement une
espèce de taxe carbone qui financerait
une partie de la protection sociale pour
que lorsque vous achetez un produit
chinois et bien en quelque sorte
il souhaite amener à payer une partie de
notre protection sociale un mot sur un
petit élément dans le budget de la
défense qui est l'achat par l'armée
française de 11 rafale supplémentaires
et c'est pour compenser la difficulté
que nous avons à vendre ce rafale à
l'étranger
c'est parce que nous avions construit
une loi de programmation militaire avec
l'idée que les exportations de rafale
nous permettrait nous de réduire nos
commandes puisque d'assaut pour
maintenir la chaîne de production
d'assaut il nous faut commander au
minimum
onze avions par an soit un avion par
mois donc ça signifie douma fallon
n'arrive toujours pas à le vendre à
l'écouté j'espère que nous allons y
arriver j'ai cru comprendre que abou
dhabi avait une commande potentielle là
bas commence à regarder ce qui se passe
du côté des américains coûté chaudes
discussions longues parce que ce sont
des décisions qui sont des acteurs
fondateur pour un pays ce sont des
décisions qui engagent ce pays pour une
quarantaine d'années puisqu'un système
d'armes comme celui ci c'est au moins 35
et 40 ans et donc il est logique que les
discussions prennent un mini sur abu
dhabi ni sur le brésil c'est fichu
chagny fiche une part bien sûr ça peut
continuer par parenthèse c'est le rafale
de monsieur dassault serge dassault ça
vous secret que serge dassault rachète
le journal le parisien ou pas au nom du
pluralisme dans la presse je pense qu'on
est honnêtement je pense qu'on a besoin
de pluralisme dans la presse en effet
donc ce n'est pas souhaitable
je pense que nous avons besoin d'avoir
un système médiatique qui repose sur des
groupes indépendants et donc ces rejets
sont par exemple s'il était propriétaire
du figaro 2-7 parisien pas une bonne
chose
je pense qu'on a besoin de pluralisme
dans un
la démocratie française vous mouiller
pas je vous lis les sauts qui fait le
rafale et dont les bains je viens de
vous le dire en quelque sorte je ne sais
pas c'est pas la personne qui est en
cause ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
avons besoin de groupes locaux parisiens
qui soit indépendant et qui ne reposent
pas tous sur le même capital est à peu
près la même chose que ce que vous dites
non voilà allez on passe au jeudi et
l'air remous justement autour des
conflits d'intérêts c'est martin hirsch
ancien haut commissaire aux solidarités
actives qui joue cette semaine les
chevaliers blancs
tout est dans le titre de son livre pour
en finir avec les conflits d'intérêts
comment une responsabilité politique
peut ne pas faire bon ménage avec
d'autres fonctions notamment dans le
privé dans le collimateur de martin
hirsch notamment jean françois copé à la
fois député et avocat d'affaires accusés
c'est évidemment très mal reçue par
l'intéressé mejia mans kawa le livre
agace avant même sa sortie quand martin
hirsch part en croisade contre les
conflits d'intérêts ses anciens
partenaires se lâche
à commencer par ceux directement visé
par les ouvrages il n'est certainement
pas le mieux placé pour donner des
leçons de morale aux autres il n'est pas
procureur est lui même ayant commis tout
de même un véritable conflit d'intérêts
en étant ministre et en faisant voter
une loi qui lui a permis de créer son
propre poste après avoir quitté le
gouvernement
je trouve tout ça est pas très
convenable
jean françois copé accusé de cumuler ses
fonctions de député avec ses activités
d'avocat d'affaires
le patron du groupe préfère la taca la
défense tout comme certains de ses
collègues
indigné par l'attitude jugée déloyale de
l'ancien commissaire aux solidarités
actives cherche là vraiment
manque à tous ses devoirs de solidarité
quand on a décidé comme il l'a fait
entrer dans un gouvernement on se
conduit dignement le jour on en sort
mélange des genres ou climat de
suspicion certains tout de même
s'interroge sur la compatibilité de ces
doubles casquettes je ne serai pas
personnellement avocat d'affaires et
député
maintenant ça relève aussi de la
conscience pendant que d'autres
appellent à légiférer et pour plus de
transparence on peut pas d'un côté dire
c'est pas bien de cumuler avec les
mandats de maire et de l'autre
multiplier les cumuls de fonctions qui
ont des rapports entre elles nous devons
changer nos moeurs il ya trop de
facilité dans le cadre politique
française et on accepte trop de
situations on devrait pas être acceptée
martin hirsch aurait-il mis le doigt là
où ça fait mal pour en finir avec le
conflit d'intérêts une commission a été
chargée par le président de la
république d'étudier le problème alors
le président de votre groupe à
l'assemblée françois sauvadet a dit moi
personnellement je ne serai pas à la
fois député avocat d'affaires ont gagné
la même chose je les dis avant martin
hirsch je considère qu'on a vécu une
période de grande moralisation de la vie
politique française au milieu des années
90 avec la loi sur le financement de la
vie politique et qu'aujourd'hui il faut
franchir une nouvelle étape et cette
nouvelle étape elle passe par de
nouvelles règles notamment sur le cumul
des mandats je pense qu'il va falloir un
jour ou l'autre
qu'on cesse cette tradition française
qui est unique en europe qui est celle
du cumul des mandats moi je défends
l'idée de la suppression du cumul on ne
peut pas avoir des parlementaires qui
sont trop saoul influence de leurs
mandats locaux
la parlementaire doit être abandonnée
tout au moins à l'assemblée nationale
puisque le sénat représente les
collectivités locales donc on pourrait
admettre un cumul modérée au sénat pour
tenir compte de cette spécificité du
sénat la martinière notamment gérard
longuet qui sénateurs étaient également
avec une mission de conseil pour gdf
suez dans le même temps est-ce que ça
vous choque
maintenant je termine et le deuxième
point à mon avis sur lequel nous devons
progresser c'est celui en effet du cumul
de fonctions privées avec les mandats
politiques et je pense par exemple que
si être médecin est nécessaire lorsqu'on
est parlementaire parce que si vous êtes
chirurgien vous n'exercez pas pendant
cinq ans compte tenu des progrès de la
médecine cinq ans plus tard vous ne
pouvez pas vous classez quand en
revanche je peux le dire puisque moi
j'ai aussi fait le choix de par
équivalence de passer le barreau et j'ai
constaté très rapidement que lorsque
vous êtes dans un cabinet d'avocats vous
risquez même si vous faites votre métier
avec le plus grand scrupule de créer le
soupçon et le doute et donc il faut
créer un certain nombre quoi il faut te
élaboré un certain nombre de règles très
précises qui évite que notre démocratie
soit sous le soupçon
voilà c'était dans la loi ou dans l'auto
10,6 à l'image de discipline vous ne
l'aurez pas ça m'a donc et pour tout
vous dire je pense que ce genre de
règles vous aurez beaucoup de mal à les
faire passer par le parlement et que ce
genre de règles il appartiendra
maintenant un président de la république
de le proposer dans le cadre d'un
référendum qui permettrait aux français
de pouvoir régler ce genre de son début
de mandat dont quand on a une demande
c'est un programme de candidat à la
présidentielle mais je vous donne des
idées allez on passe à la journée de
vendredi avec cette petite annonce
villepiniste cherche députés alliés pour
créer un groupe à l'assemblée
tractations en coulisses en cette fin de
semaine pour les députés villepinistes
ils ont jusqu'au 2 octobre date
d'ouverture de ces demandes in her pour
constituer un groupe parlementaire et
avoir droit aux avantages qui vont avec
notamment des financements des moyens de
secrétariat des chauffeurs il faut
quinze députés pour créer un groupe et
parmi ceux qui ont été approchés des
députés du nouveau centre y en a même un
qui n'a pas été indifférent aux chants
des sirènes c'est thomas soulier qui est
parti à la chasse aux infos ils sont dix
dix députés villepinistes à la recherche
d'alliés objectif en nouveau groupe à
l'assemblée nationale est pour l'instant
le compte n'y est pas il faut en trouver
bien à l'assemblée nationale
problème ils ont du mal à les trouver
ces cinq députés
car voilà les villepinistes ont toujours
leur carte à l'ump à l'heure en face
c'est toujours la même réponse
moi je ne participerai par un groupe
avec des gens qui sont toujours encarté
ump j'ai quitté l'ump à trois ans avant
tout le monde et j'ai été clair au net
pour moi il ya une condition central
c'est qu'on soit pas dans l'ambiguïté
que on et de la clarté et on peut pas
être en même temps à l'ump et dans le la
confrontation avec l'ump mais certains
seraient prêts à sauter le pas parmi eux
nicolas perruchot le député du nouveau
centre rêve d'un groupe indépendant face
à l'ump on a eu de longues discussions
avec avec hervé morin comme avec
françois sauvadet je pense que l'un et
l'autre m'ont demandé de rester
maintenant vous savez ma décision elle
reste suspendu à ces éléments là bien
entendu qui compte mais pas simplement
on aurait intérêt en tout cas nous au
nouveau centre effectivement avoir une
ligne un peu différentes et divergentes
parfois et surtout à poser des actes au
moment des votes des différents textes à
l'ump
toutes ces manoeuvres font sourire et
aucun ne croit en ce futur groupe on est
trop près des élections dont tous ceux
qui sont là qui vont partir de l'ump
c'est faire un groupe
ils seront élus comment après en
s'opposant à nicolas sarkozy ses députés
prennent en effet en risque perdre leur
investiture ump pour les prochaines
élections législatives en 2012
qu'est ce que vous dites à votre ami
j'imagine nicolas perruchot il fait
partie du nouveau centre pour l'instant
je lui ai dit que non je lui ai dit
écoute franchement si tu penses que
dominique de villepin est à centriste
fais moi signe
vous pensez que envoyait un instant à
l'instant françois bayrou
vous pensez à un rapprochement possible
entre françois bayrou et dominique de
villepin
bakou tiges l'élu j'ai compris il avait
déjeuné ensemble qu'ils avaient imaginé
ensemble de confluence puis après j'ai
entendu françois bayrou dira le
contraire
dix jours avant il avait expliqué que la
candidature de dominique strauss kahn
serait pour lui
éventuellement une bonne chose pour un
nouvel
accord avec le parti socialiste puis
deux mois avant il disait du bien du
président la république qu'il avait
considéré est estimé comme un enfant
barbare dans un ouvrage dont sont
rencontrés ya pas si longtemps dans
l'été donc en termes de clarté et de
confusion qu'il appelait de ses voeux il
est absolument exceptionnel clarté il a
quand même présenté cette semaine un
shadow cabinet talla britannique un
cabinet fantôme entre guillemets c'est à
dire avec une équipe et des gens qui
sont chargés un peu des portefeuilles
ministériels qu'il pourrait occuper dans
la perspective j'imagine d'une
présidentielle qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette initiative
on va vous voyez bien que c'est
initiative elle est faite pour cacher
une réalité c'est qu'il ya plus personne
n'a pris personne ya ceux qui sont là à
côté de lui je regardais des parfums de
la doc la binette et et regardez l'état
aujourd'hui des fédérations et du modem
et vous aurez compris bernard debré dit
sortir de l'ump c'est par toutes les
chances d'être réélu notamment pour un
villepiniste ou pour un nouveau centre
bell et la même chose pour un député
si vous allez dans un groupe avec
dominique de villepin vous savez la vie
politique
elle est faite de rebondissements et
dans l'autre sens en sens inverse elle
est traître au sein de la majorité
ces difficultés pour marquer sa
différence mais moi je suis pas dedans
et pas un peu de je suis pas dans ça un
centrisme d'opposition chez dans un
centrisme de construction g je veux
faire en sorte que notre famille soit
représentée pour ses valeurs pour ses
projets j'ai essayé à travers cette
émission de vous en présenter
quelques-uns je veux que le parti qui à
la fois porte l'idée du global parce que
je pense que nous devons affronter la
globalisation mais aussi du local de
nouvelles solidarités vous ai parlé de
notre société de la reconnaissance
je pourrais vous ai parlé d'europe je
pense que tout cela nous amène
simplement à regarder les choses en face
il ya des français qui se reconnaissent
dans ce message envoyé que dans
notamment les enquêtes d'opinion avec
les deux personnalités qui seraient les
plus à même de porter ces valeurs un peu
sociale et centriste ils sont
aujourd'hui à l'ump vous le disiez tout
à l'heure pour jean louis borloo et
dominique de villepin qui est encore
donc donc vous risquez de vous faire
squeezé par cette candidature centriste
à l'intérieur de l'ump comme il y avait
eu la candidature de balladur face à la
biopsie candidat de l'ump aura qu'un
seul bris mais à ce moment là il y en
aura un autre qui prendra peut-être ses
distances à un moment donné
croyez moi je vais pas écoutez moi ce
que je sais c'est qu'il ya les élections
présidentielles ont démontré une chose
dans l'histoire c'est que ça n'est
jamais ce que vous croyez 18 mois al
avance c'est vrai ce vendredi c'est
aussi la décision sur la date du procès
de jacques chirac dans l'affairé des
emplois fictifs de la ville de paris on
sait qu'il ya eu un accord avec la
mairie de paris le tribunal
correctionnel vient de décider de
reporter ce procès entre novembre 2010
et mars 2011
vous pensez que c'est une bonne chose
qui est un procès de jacques chirac dans
le cadre de cette affaire ou qu'on
devrait s'en passer sous pose une
question est ce qu'on se poserait cette
question là s'il s'agissait d'un autre
français en accord avec la mairie de
paris
cela poserait pas et donc il ya pas de
raison que jacques chirac ne soit pas
voilà il est redevenu un justiciable
comme un autre appartement c'est un
français comme les autres et même s'il
s'agit d'histoires vieille en effet qu
on peut estimer pour des raisons de
santé etc etc
justice elle doit être la même pour tout
le monde profane est il pas un peu vidé
de sa substance avec l'accord trouvé
entre la mairie de paris et l'ump
voilà ça vous choque cet arrangement
écoutez moi j'aurais préféré qu'il n'y
en ait pas mais personne ne peut
s'opposer à un accord entre deux parties
qui sont autonomes et indépendantes mais
je pense que l'est que la question qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure qui est une
nouvelle étape dans la démocratie
française est bien aussi elle participe
de ce genre de comportement qui à mon
sens il faut bannir
c'est sur ces mots que nous avons nous
quitter a vraiment merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité sur ces trois
quarts d'heure quant à nous mêmes on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine on va
ramener les sites de nos chaînes
www.publicsenat.fr et pour mir plus bien
sûr www.al cpa elle.fr merci à vous
merci heureusement la défense président
du nouveau centre et la semaine
prochaine croit savoir